[Applaudissements]
cette édition d'hier vous avez parlé de
la fête clandestine au but de chaumont
et j'ai retrouvé une photo de cette fête
dans laquelle on peut voir que les
jeunes s'éclatent
regardez quand j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle j'ai zoomé dans la photo et
regarder qui j'ai découvert
[Applaudissements]
dès qu'il fait chaud l'uia genton palois
n'a jamais cherché delphine et à vous
avez aussi parlé de la réouverture des
écoles avec un prof
alors j'ai un petit jeu pour vous le
public vous ai joué voilà à votre avis
laquelle de ces deux personnes est
autorisé à accompagner une sortie
scolaire en france
donc les femmes voilées à tous et vous
des dragons les sénateurs je vous
préviens vous calmer sur les musulmans
sinon je loge gilles verdez enfin il est
superflu et enfin vous avez fait un
débat sur un petit animateur débutants
cyril hanouna comme il débute en avait
parlé pendant 32 minutes 32 minutes
le sujet était si lille doit-il
présenter le débat du deuxième tour
présidentiel rien c'est la une du
magazine m édité par le monde et une
petite phrase de marlène schiappa qui
ont agité la sphère politique la semaine
dernière en 2022
c'est lui qui devrait être présenté le
débat de l'entre-deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle
après la rumeur de sa candidature la
rumeur de ta présentation du débat sinon
on fait un putsch directement je te dis
la vérité on a le digicode de l'elysée
la nuit on prend le pouvoir
d'ailleurs ton avis théière nelly
garnier la conseillère à la mairie de
paris a relancé le débat sur ta
candidature
j'aimerais plutôt que ça soit à moins
qu'ils leur fassent ils leurs leçons
puis tant qu'à faire si vous voulez
vraiment compté dans les vapes politique
année hanouna 2022 bon moi je vais pas
voter pour vous ah oui mais on verra on
verra mais moi je trouve que tu en kata
c'est vous qui apportez quelque chose au
débat voilà un mineur 2022
en plus je suis sûr que ce serait un
quinquennat super sympa dark athena
d'ailleurs voici le dark athena résumé
dans notre documentaire historique
babacan ips
[Musique]
8 mai 2022 cyril hanouna devient
président de la république française il
bat au deuxième tour le professeur à
août après que l'on ait découvert que la
chloroquine injecté aux marseillais leur
a fait pousser un troisième bras juin
le président ano d'un homme nicolas
pernikoff ministre de la jeunesse et de
la quiche tu as tes malatesta mais les
limites
il déclare je cite je suis dégoûté sa
mère je voulais l'intérieur j'ai le
somment de ouf juillet 2022 suite à son
obsession concernant l'islamophobie
qu'il voit partout même dans une
bouteille d'eau
gilles verdez devient ministre des
cultes quant à kim glos suite à ces
propos tenu quotidiennement elle devient
ministre des incultes septembre 2022 les
députés du parti des babas blick un vote
à l'unanimité la loi
j'entends qui reconnaît les influenceurs
comme des êtres humains à part entière
doit une sensibilité novembre 2022 le
président hanat nomme ali baddou
ambassadeur en alaska sans chauffage
ali baddou depuis qu'il est dans plus
dans le groupe car à lille peut toute sa
tête décembre 2022 le parlement concède
au maire du mans steevy une subvention
pour que la ville est enfin accès à
l'eau chaude
janvier 2023 sans prévenir les allemands
attaquent la france après que le psg et
rebattus le bayern de munich en ligue
des champions la ministre des anciens
combattants
isabelle morini bosc qui a déjà vécu les
deux premières guerres contre
l'allemagne déclare oh non pas encore
cyril hanouna défi angela merkel en
déclarant je n'aurais pas kim khloé la
lorraine mai 2023
après avoir passé un an pour fermer tout
seul dans les studios de tpm paix
benjamin castaldi sort du silence je
cite
mais bon sang à qui je rends l'antenne à
cette heure cette réponse
vous l'aurez dans le prochain numéro de
ba baca lips
c
mais tu sais j'ai toujours pour finir
mon cher cyrine ces derniers temps
beaucoup de gens sur les réseaux
essayent de profiter des faits tragiques
pour nous opposer
alors j'aimerais saluer ce soir les
familles de la policière tuée à
rambouillet stéphanie vont fermer et
sarah limite response en bonne santé
merci
[Applaudissements]